first thing I talk about it college
education I'm not a computer science
graduate white background i would say
aerospace engineer forgot natural
physics do good aerospace engineering
computational fluid dynamics but that
not my college I and so one of them
interesting things to be just about
software industry is it's an industry
where a lot of people who've been
successful in it don't necessarily come
from the traditional background then
from that curriculum as an undergraduate
degree and it's actually sort of a
reason for that my mind event the story
of it you know I got a school I worked
at NASA one of the biggest companies you
possibly work for nation
rockets and that was an exciting to you
know I felt very small and not really
contributing in a big way and I was part
of NASA which is really cool when I was
a kid that was what I wanted to do but
you know when I got there he was working
you know it wasn't fulfilling in terms
of that individual role so I started out
looking for how could I have a bigger
impact as an engineer how could I wake
up every day and feel like you know I
built a lot of things I made things
happen you know why my efforts really
impacted the world or at least I saw
some change happening so that led me to
software and it starts right both sides
oh so the transition out of NASA got me
into just luckily a story called trilogy
that we were after a while down in
Austin Texas so that was the first sort
of started
i was lucky i joined a guy who dropped
out of sanford a classic startup story
the crazy startup guy but Joe basically
knew a lot about the industry had a lot
of very different people around him and
it gave me the islands have any joint
back early in that company to build
software from strategy to think like a
product manager is opposed to everything
that the company is doing in terms of
trying to define a product and they
fight and that as we grew luckily this
week I made it very successful so as we
grew I got to build teams cial teams
operated successfully and kind of go
through the whole lab experiment up to
we were about 15
people in 250 million so I walk in the
door there's nothing and that was kind
of trajectory so you know that's
obviously a very forming experience in
my career just to make that transition
and I see all of that so then I took
those lessons and said all right what do
I want to do man that was successful
yeah yeah so I think you a couple of
things I think Joe was really really
early on it was the founder in a very
customer centric approach this was pre
and I know a lot of people out here in
the crowd that that may be prepared for
a concept but you know this is an Arab
enterprise software right so a trilogy
built with software to help fortune 500
companies to sell the products better
kind of reduce error rates so not sexy
gaming apps or websites but even in that
endeavor we really tried hard to ever
changing the customer was to get to that
person
the enterprise and to make sure that the
engineer the people are actually writing
on the software worse exposed directly
to those people and urgent requirements
directly so we were doing sort of an
early version of strong the force from
was a concept right we just had this
intuition that this was the right way to
do things since none of us had a
classical background it wasn't like we
were doing this for the textbook this
was just kind of our you know our gut
feel of how we would live right a clear
engineers so that's something that's
stuck with me in my career for sure it's
giving industries where you could be
close to the customer not very three
layers back and not for you know
organizational groups between the
engineers and the ultimate customer and
you know other lessons there were around
you want to create value early so you
know when you look at your product when
you're starting to build it don't stay
on a white board which the market would
do very quickly get out to the market
and work with these customers and make
them pay for the product you're building
that's what's going to validate am I on
the right track am i doing the right
so very incremental approach to how you
create that value to your product as
your
company so that was interesting when we
are gay right in the internet and I was
exciting and so I've with front end of
that so a trilogy we built out the very
early website totally in Pearl right
there were no languages listen to
anything it wasn't an actor you're
literally writing stripping on the back
end hoping it would work on a Linux box
of it if a million people can yeah that
didn't scale too well but you know we
built a very sophisticated technology on
top of this we weren't just building you
know basic publishing site or basic
website we had built the system where
people to come and configuring build
computers very sophisticated computers
and then by right so we were part of
this computer industry we understood
sort of engineering complexity and at
the time this was a hero where you could
buy separate motherboards and cpus
memory and put it all
computer a lot of people did that so you
know it sophisticated business logic and
technical logic on the back end of this
system in that early internet era so
that got me excited about the internet
that was a trilogy but then when I left
trilogy we did living calm which was
more of a classic oh we're going to be
retailers we're going to go out of the
internet we're going to make a billion
dollars well it's gonna be great so this
was benchmark funded Dave burn as soon
as one of the darlings of the year there
who threw a lot of money at it and said
how fast you feel one of the biggest
e-tailer type companies in the world
amazon was probably about two years at
this point they were just starting to
ramp it around him but we're talking 50
million
not where they are today that you know
the vc's had their eye on doesn't set
out detailing is going to happen and we
want to build for more companies like
this so if we could pump money and fast
enough can we build companies fast
enough so the lesson there was no they
wanted us to build this entire very
complex company in about 18 months and
they had all the way in world right as I
said I know here's 120 way boxes over a
couple funding rounds but we had access
to that so you ought to be able to build
a fire company that
right it's never that easy right so what
I i took the lesson we could build a lot
of cool technologies of that money that
was fun but being it was like a lesson
in how fast can you grow a company if
you try it grow really fast with the
problems have happened so you know we
did a lot of outsourced engineering and
trying to get groups to communicate and
coordinate together was obviously one of
the large problems that we had
everything but we architect position so
that every do their own module it was a
clear functional unit to what na team
built so that there wasn't necessarily
daily interaction between the teams that
that allowed each of the teams to move
fairly fast but you still have it at
that pace teams got out soon and when
they got out of saying the software
obviously could integrate well then you
ran into problems so but on the internet
exciting you know we
very high scale you know one of the
better recognize websites of that era
the challenge became okay as we're
building this technology really fast a
business is trying to adopt becoming a
tailor so we took about you people
classic retail stuck them on top of this
we're running as fast as we can as it is
and all of these
macys you know basically buyers that
probably haven't seen a computer where
our urgent thing on right so there are
the people picking the products and
we're going to put online figuring out
how to put that database so those things
that
technically couldn't stay synchronized
with how fast with a living and we
didn't get good requirements from our
customer on the end
this back end side was trying to fill
built this catalogue that then of course
internet we didn't actually have the
customers yet so we're guessing at the
product we're trying to build right so
those are just depends that no matter
throw at it you can't fix it in one
month or two months so you know with
ultimately the company did well she got
a line sold a lot of product and the
funding was the problem we couldn't
scale the revenue the actual customer
adoption fast enough for you know the
money that we instead consumers will
adopt in time and there was this cycle
of you know merchants and put product
online that they had
learn from customers you know what
products did you feel when I put this
online if you didn't buy why why didn't
you buy right so this is also the early
stage wasn't huge you know sort of
analytical system on the back end so
they have very basic reports but they
were trying to learn from their customer
and that just takes time there's no
amount of technology you can pour in
that just you know in two months to make
you find a customer base know them well
serve them well have the right products
online at the right price right the
beauty of Amazon is it's been around me
offer but 15 years and I mean they just
continually learn about that they we had
a phase where basically the veterans who
would try to monetize any way they could
say hey can we take the software and
sell them right after a of a software
company
but ultimately this was just a less than
B seat right they were very original
bottle that they put together we
probably could apply there was a company
that came out of this actually went to
work for several years later
ATT the art technology so we actually
were company that helped them build
their entire ecommerce engine on that
system we shared code with them so you
know we're not only have their
technology exact but uh you know so
there was a viable play to take this
thing and go become software company
become a really viable business but the
vc's just could not unlike the way the
investment company and pivot it and
therefore it was really pretty abrupt
stop right there was no
it was just luck you know we didn't make
it customers didn't come fast enough
we're shoving now you got to figure a
lot of things out yourself so CTO I like
to figure it out right so I'll sit down
there and try to build a first prototype
that is brought that obviously not
complete my deep and then hire two or
three engineers with my leads to come in
and then we start to build the software
more commercial scale we put in all the
continuous integration components and
make sure that we have a good supplement
process and they learn the domain and
then we are select the work and start to
you know subdivide and kind of build up
services or in architecture right allow
a generic kind of L a complete
functional service so they can move with
the fastest pace it can but there's
always a contract of API for how they
communicate how they integrate with each
other and that is really key like
full-stack developers is what I always
look for all right that's the early
stage like finding these people to walk
through all the layers to think
architecturally along
very important so how did you like
managed to be used for all students
yeah that's a good question to start up
you want to do that every day but you
generally end up doing that a little
later so that's where I think being a
CTO you people you got to give on some
things there's kind of my clothes mean
comments no startup you can't do
everything so you want to take that to a
point that you obviously want to find
with breaking point in so there's their
cycle as an engineering where ok I'm
going to run build a lot of future
functionality right and that's going to
make the investors happy and it's going
to the first very product out it's goin
to get our website launched but then you
want to find a time you can pull back
and say okay for three months we're not
going to do that now and you have the
hottest oral tablet when you just
launched that product so you get a set
of functionality as you make sure works
you get your success you kind of sell
that to everybody the investor is you
CEO and you know everybody excuse an
assistant inside the company and then
you have a little bit of time it so you
gotta use that time wisely baby back
over okay let's do some cross cultural
knowledge sharing its use of
documentation let's let's think through
the architecture
so you gotta do those cycles we just
can't joke every back so so this
probably yeah we'll talk about play sec
you later that running businesses they
get part i also three years ago big data
I don't like
there so that was the one that was
confronted with me
access to the first one and there are
two sides to it I can I can kind of draw
a picture of how much data we were going
to have as a company by year two or
three what we were really successful and
oh yeah that's daunting you know some of
these issues intimate sequel platforms
were describing the candle was very
attractive but then I stepped back and
said hey here it is it's your watch we
really don't have that much time
that's not my problem so I brother
explore the domain better and I will
push that problem off till here too so
we built first virgin the system on post
dress this works a lot of experience it
could write things really fast
I'd be five bugs time versus actually
working on my domain it's all the
problems that we're going to make my
company more valuable so eighty percent
of the time i'm going to choose to try
them true and you try and push off these
other problems too as late as you can in
the cycle and that's also an interesting
discussion because some people say oh my
God you never want to be engineer you
never want to redesign that's a failure
of the engineering organization I had to
manage my co-founder place like you
because I told him I think we'll rebuild
this thing probably three times along
the way because there's so many of them
this is such a complicated system and we
don't have money so there's all sorts of
constraints on people money your own
skills and experience right you can't
build it right the first time so don't
try and I just got a look at the
problems that need to be in front of you
the next 12 months pick tools and
capabilities and allow you to be
successful there
live to fight another day and you know
no single side i also had sort of a gpio
is it really to be the new vendor who
ultimately succeeds here or they have a
big bang in the first two years while
this is the hot new technology but then
postgres is going to come in you know
verdict is going to come in and
everybody also going to come and attack
Sakana figure this out there should be
other way to handle the big data flow
into market inferences probably suck so
I also try to let those problems they
solve themselves because one of my job's
is to make sure I can't solve every from
right we're not going to get enough fun
to do that so I got to pick my battles
sometimes creating constraints and say
look I do not only one solving that
problem therefore
problem is solved for an additive to how
I adopt the technology in the my company
of solving problem my customers so in
this current day I thinks back to make
sure your little while ago which is
focus on one thing at a time don't try
everything at once and so the earlier
discussions around velocity feature
Bruce's stability and maintainability
and scalability but also with it with
all these factors like you know I tend
to focus and try to make major progress
one of the legs of the stool often so if
its performance so you just find it a
business in performance was our problem
right to this discussion thumbtack I
needed it an appliance that inserted
that scale so we could make enough money
off this product that we built so okay
the theme for the next month and a half
is performance and scale right now
that's something I'm focused on I'm
spending a lot of my time on to find
thumbtack to building this project right
to get them set up so that they can be
successful and ensure that that happens
so this unnecessarily and performance
issue
all team photos of performance and last
two months yeah
x is up to say because thats so other
parts of the team or I just not his
hands on them at that time so you gotta
let things run a bit while you're you
gotta figure out reunion spending time
make progress so again that's that old
you know gonna start up the dist aren't
enough hours in a day so for you is one
person to try and solve at all so now
some things may not go totally the
direction you want them to go but you
gotta trust people you have
usually say the team on spending time
yeah yeah for this amount of is their
primary focus I mean it's not that you
don't do anything else not myopic that
that's the one that you're really trying
to make progress on everything else you
try to at least keep going while you're
trying to make real progress in one key
area and usually
trying to
one morning with songs
exactly can you help them understand the
rationale here's why I'm focus on that
why it's the most important addition as
to where you're going yeah yeah sure so
the next axle progression is yet we were
data scientists we kind of our own dog
food we built our own platform that you
know did this science in a pretty custom
novel way nobody's really ever thought
of it before so first we're just
arbitrarily taking out the finished
product and we go sell that customers
that base a lot of money that's that's
great but now we're starting to see the
customers are coming to us saying well
I've got some proprietary data I don't
necessarily want you to do the data
science because I'm going to share this
information with you it is sensitive
data therefore i need a great platform
into my enterprise and then teach my
people how to use it and then they can
do this so we're now looking at how we
build an analytical platform that can be
delivered either you know some of my
cloud but also because the proprietary
nature of some of this day
inside feels companies so that they
needed to do this themselves for service
yeah we're only going to this black line
of service even if it got the point
inside the data center it would be a
solar module right something that we
plop into that data center that bronze
or it connects up to their whole
infrastructure and it provides a service
to them these cases that
yeah so they gonna make money off right
now is mobile attitudes and your mates
let's all around in real time when
you're using your app when it's an ad
driven application a lot of
location-based and go past the location
that's the only piece of information
will use to do these predictors to save
for college student or be interested in
food right now your primary shopping for
you know high-end clothing so we just
know all these behaviors and that's
that's the kind of profiling and
segmentation and you do on the phone so
so you kind of look
deuce that Michael to be the sort of the
graphic which gives you the ability
yeah so yeah I meant to get a little
more detail on to detail so we'll take
this information we break the world up
into 100 meter panels so in North
America versus billion under Peter talks
so that's the resolution we're at vs zip
code targeting or you know kind of old
school marketing so we're orders of
magnitude more detail and what pops out
and you get to that bubble of detail is
you know the real behaviors and
predictions and repeatable patterns that
people have most people are creatures of
habit right thing visit the same places
every day they kind of walk the same
paths tend to repeat themselves so it
becomes predicted pretty quickly and
then you see you know so therefore the
haters become repeatable as well and by
behaviour I mean like you people
searching for Chinese food restaurant
right people are hungry people going out
to a bar different people are now
looking for a movie people
right exactly so you know that's the
math we built right here build these
maps we have these behaviors understood
we contextualizing in terms of sort of
the location as well and that allows us
to propagate model out beyond the people
would learn from so there's a set of
people we learn from right it's like all
these interesting behaviors happen then
we figure out this sort of location
characteristics that are influencing or
predicting that type of behavior and
then we see we can replicate that
throughout North America because we have
the entire map right we know where all
the businesses are where all the
location characteristics are so now I
can cover all in north america through
not you know i don't have to say every
person in north america to understand
every person to north america hiking
trails only had angel funding 1 million
dollars basically dumping myself and
first employee who started with us it
was a DBA location analytics type of
person so he understood GIS data which
is our first problem is getting you to
store it in structure and then we have a
sort of functional analyst of markets
point number two was she'd been in
marketing and she kind of understood a
little bit of the custom space if it's
the idea marketing segmentation so kind
of got a first proxy for customer in
genetic and then I had one day to
scientists at that time
yep and so we spent the first year half
just working with the data and didn't
want to grow the team at all because we
were just exploring for trying to
understand what we're doing
sure limit the amount of exploration we
could do with the hire more people would
create noise as well so we want to be
kind of focused so explicitly
yeah and so the early phase was we could
prove we could ingest a lot of day we
could cleanse it we could put it on a
map we could you know so a we got access
to the types of information we would
need be we seem to know how to store it
can manage it and see we could run some
kind of algorithm on top of it we didn't
get home right outta rhythm you know the
million or billion dollar algorithm but
at least we're starting to do data
science on top of the day one so that
was a good enough proof for the first
days and then we got it
yeah writing codes definitely post fun
yeah yeah so yeah I guess it's a little
kinetics in a second how do you how do
you write any code now and how do you
make sure that you stay fresh doesn't
seem to come back to Olivia stage stuff
which means that you sort of need to be
able to come back to writing code
because there will be pretty good at
spending eight years the first code are
like all right you don't want to be too
gnostic how do you balance
yeah I haven't written code I mean yep a
little fun stuff on the side but I have
a brick code so there are times when you
get too busy to move on beyond that side
that's why again like the four year
cycles is that I can get back to coding
spend at least one to two years coding
in one to two years scaling you know I
would be nervous to get much further
away from them for that so yeah and that
was the first max now just nuts and then
we got series a funding and move to New
York since where the customers were at
least that's what we are premise was
marketing was our customer and I decided
to hire one more take scientist and I
hired a triple PhD mathematicians and we
were going to do a lot of algorithms so
could optimize the hell out of anything
and compile things my data scientist by
the way was a applied physicist which
it's a couple of here is unlike bit like
people who can take mathematics and
model complex systems within a model of
biology
or the early universe or something
that's the domain that worked it so
they've already got this discipline in
this kind of comfort around math and
using math to describe really complex
problems and all the various
permutations of how I might go about
that versus against or somebody coming
out of maybe masters PhD Comp Sci
machine learning person you know that's
a different type of data scientist me so
I didn't focus so much on you know is
this robotics and it's this machine work
right and the classic comp sighs and
says I know there's a mathematical
problem I'm going to have a Saturday
it'll reduce it model up in some way and
then I'm going to use some math to be
able to correlate and extract and
understand we worried too tiring the
typical PhD I that you should be sitting
around doing that
yeah absolutely and then so yeah that's
part of the part of the interview is he
coded and so nicely to the he was yell
PhD physics studying the early universe
but then he went to hedge fund so he did
finance which showed that he's shipped
every morning and stuff had to work and
if he's out really broke down you know
people lost millions of dollars so he'd
actually been on the action side of this
and he's interested he was then this is
another important thing he was
interested in software i also didn't
want a data scientist to its theoretical
i've had no interest in writing software
because you get these types of cultures
where its throat over the wall you know
I model everything in MATLAB are here
you go so yeah that's your software like
you guys don't build some software does
that so I wanted to make sure that in
the beginning of this process there was
a lot of linkage between data science
and software thinking about the full
manifestation of that algorithm not just
deer that's it so very pragmatic got
absolutely alright so now so we're
basically a number-crunching backhand
system so all of our testing systems are
pretty simple right it's straight to
data addicts and do
on the back end so yeah you I front end
piece of the world so let's turn yeah so
what we do is our data scientists review
gets tested several 01 is just is the
algorithm implemented correctly which is
kind of like a math test but it says
okay you just mess up the basic
functions and then you have a set of
data as a vote by grant through that
function i would expect the result of
the episode of the test and route 70
used so we can all get the expect rizal
that then we know if its direction
so it's not actually sophisticated
testing it's just that you got to put
the effort into testing you have to
think through a decent enough you know
created test data set is actually the
interesting problem because again back
to one where I got pop right let's like
okay the sample data was so far from
reality it missed like 10 or 11 major
problems at the current rate 60 yeah
yeah I actually haven't thought about a
man so immersive what I'm doing it it's
truly the answer that but but I believe
under the know something that it's
always adjacent right it's not like I
just jumped way way out of bound so the
thing I like about what we're going to
place like kids were immersed everything
that's happening in the mobile consumer
cycle which is the biggest cycle that's
ever happened bigger than the internet
right now that people are on smartphones
versus the amount of people who adopted
globally is a pretty amazing trend the
intimacy and the amount they're using
that device is amazing so it's not just
about any commerce and YouTube so I we
really know we're in a 10-year cycle
here I mean I'm just fascinated by that
I'm in the middle of it I get to see all
about chew on all that data do you know
so as we build this platform hopefully
we're going to help disrupt multiple
areas even within right now not not a
separate covenant so maybe that's my
goal on this remove this is the first 1i
can last more than four years coming up
on four years I gotta gotta figure it
out at some point I'm going all the job
six years eight years that's key for
everybody as we got to know your blind
spots so for me
the process of people side I'm not in
manager that's just not what I want to
do every day I never got managed to
actually the self-managed so I kind of
created my own career and kind of nobody
ever directly management instance in
this job I'm in there were my network of
people I talked to but it wasn't like
this active you know to hear manager
leader of person so I don't have success
models of that I didn't create myself
that way so I think I'm probably pretty
bad at doing so I look for ok any
balances we're going to grow a bigger
team people are going to need feedback
on a continual basis and kind of gross
and you know understanding you know
hiding something is focused on those
types of things so I look for somebody
who's my partner who kind of compliments
my weaknesses / not diameter
we'd interest in and they balance and
it's not that it's less valuable and
meaningful and necessary it's that
that's about so now I'll expend more of
my time thing about how do I kind of
designed the company to do these things
that are disruptive and make sure
they're valuable and they actually work
kind of car through the big problems
with the organization so I work
cross-discipline collaboratively to
evolve an entire organization but that's
different to be a manager who every day
s is it okay who gets a raise this one
who who needs you know to go to a class
because they need to be a little better
ask java or to do or whatever right so
you know that's just an example and then
you know technologies we get our blind
spots for me so I've got to find people
who help me I understand functionally
haven't done a lot of different things
but you know I'm not a level that's kind
of above all of that and somebody you
know it's much deeper to be much better
Kevin are employed on qantas by far our
group postgres guy stan is definitely
the Duke guy so I always end up finding
the chief architects of the leaders
inside organization
on their piece of the stacked
so what exciting
yeah like I said before about every
other in here I want a challenge yeah
that's when i leave is when i get bored
when i get bored i've gone so yeah to
the point where i guess is addictive
cracking how I have to be
that's like we don't know anything
everything is a challenge everyday you
wake up you're like oh my god I don't
know how to do 10 things i don't know
i'm gonna get through the deck but
really is that you know i feel you know
the motivated energized by I've gotta
learn something make something work is
it easy either for me or nobody's ever
done so yeah it's all about just you
know continually being challenged and
working with great people because I'm
not I don't want get a closet do that
myself I actually want to do that
through a large organization where we
get together a great set of people and
figuring out how to put together a UH
scientists and software engineers
marketers to solve this problem is
interesting so the problem isn't just
solved from software an algorithm it's
you know it's bigger than that
so you know ultimately we want to get
there the devotion is are we going to be
able to Europe with our analytics
technology us is a huge marketing market
so to build a billion-dollar company we
can do it here but most of the companies
we work with do business over there so
they're going to be wanting us to do it
anyway so we'll get there but we're not
pushing we're letting our customers push
it and there are challenges right so
some of them are cultural behavioral
because these models are about your
consumption habits if Europeans behavior
different their preferences are
different so that will change models and
so there will be a level we have to get
some data scientists who have some of
that cultural knowledge it matters and
then we have to build these models will
be much faster and more efficient but we
are gonna have to build it they are
different and data relationships so some
already has purchased some of its free
something that very quality so we're
going to have to get data from different
sources to have the same coverage
instead of assets we need so there's
also some work to be down there so yeah
it's not it's not a super simple
challenge take some time you know I
didn't architect to like be SCT out and
in some ways I don't that's their one
the leader or the guy I just like our
problems and interesting things and I
like to have control of that I think the
controlling factor problem that's it but
you know just be a good engineer work on
really interesting challenges then the
success will come all right if you're if
you're actually building good people
around you
you know working on the process working
on the technology and you get three or
four or five wins and you get networks
of people that you know good things
happen so to me it's just about that if
you're interested in you know being an
engineer you know just being around
other engineers who are great it's a
good thing and being around people
better that's another thing for me is
like I think I got better because I was
not afraid to always have people better
reporting to me or not like a nuanced I
got 80 PhD is reporting to me okay
that's insane like how does that even
work had to say everyone once part of it
but do you know so I are highly that as
an opportunity right it's that's great
so you know I look for organizations and
groups in places where you just
surrounded by people who are going to
challenge every day to be great but then
you know good things will happen
experience
does it get easier in your a good time
actually we're continuing on that
teachers are working with different
metric problems but do you feel you've
become more but all the time to make the
correct decisions I'll take a right time
yeah you know I think it's such a hard
problem where I doing a start-up that
you never feel good because you're
always going to make mistake lots of us
takes tons of mistakes I try not to make
the same mistakes that's useful but yeah
I've been surprised because I actually
thought it would get easier maybe this
is depressing yeah it doesn't get easy
you know I mean that's where I think you
know people who maybe stay in that same
role kind of replicate you know that I'm
a disciplinarian in this vertical you
can probably architect where it gets
easier but where you just go out on the
crazy edge it's pretty crazy every time
I got a mission question of it so you
nervous please put these two big shifts
in technology
a lot yep so we talk about what you
observe do you feel that this is sort of
metals that are violent or do you see
that actually we used to be as people
just because if this is developed was
developed into a better infrastructure
yeah now so do you think like yeah it's
still pretty artsy like one of my answer
so from the AI background you know there
there's almost the people who say we're
two years away from computers being
equal to humans and then there's people
are like a computer will never be a
human I'm much closer to a computer will
never leave unit as a programmer knowing
how when you just write an algorithm and
try to get it right then it's a simple
single algorithm it up replicating full
human brain seems kind of hard so you
know I mean last and that's the endless
a game of what we think software is
supposed to go right so yeah I think
it's there's so much left right to solve
and it's you know it's hard to the rich
Allen is interesting challenges walk
away I think the computer is becoming
much more part of everybody's daily life
and so
like the fact that it's having a bigger
impact that's more I guess more global
you know what you worked on software as
a Enterprise dude maybe you made 300
people that you know company X happy
that you deploy your app on software 300
people you know now we've needs if
you're going to grow anybody android app
and appointed 50 million people so yeah
it's a different role and you have that
kind of impact so yeah but writing
software has not gotten
easier I think we handle more data I
think we solve some harder problems so
maybe that's just the nature of it as we
keep its kind of Moore's law and reverse
like yeah the competition keeps getting
better than I keep eating it up with the
things I can think about doing to solve
that so I don't see any into that yeah
you got a job yeah for a long time
a
things talking to other things I am to
become that problem in that's kind of
what I got this little dead some level
scale so yeah I think that problem going
to continue you a bigger and you need to
figure out how to deal with that kind of
promotion
you know that's probably
then eight or ten year problem and I
think will hinge into it with some of
the stuff where I'm like you know like
we were looking certain data sets are
going to become available like inside
retail stores are down and build no
closer tracking where you can see what
aisles people go up and down so that's
different level
I had before inside the ball baiting
tease you know producing you know now
sort of the security system and you know
probably even with zig BS you know home
automation so I'll actually have a
dataset of people opening or fridge turn
it on the TV whatever they do it on
right so we can I see it as this
interesting model where we hopefully can
just kind of be adding these data sets
into what we do and slowly kind of
digesting at it
you promise yes except when you hire
people for technical leadership roles so
what actually did you look for what
attributes do you feel distinguish
distinguishing technical leaders comment
really job
right so you got to be technically on
top of your game that's important but
critical is you've got to know how to
accomplish things through other people
because you're never going to go with
anything mark aah yeah there's
occasional guy who's going to write the
iphone app in his basement 5 million
before you use it you know he'll retire
off that but most of these endeavors
become larger companies larger companies
require a decent set of people to get
together and work on a really hard
problem and figure out how to work
together so somebody who has done that
before kazutaka so I Tiger right he's
done that but who has those skills and
kind of thinks about the people element
of writing songs which is actually the
more challenging part than writing the
lines of code so they're sensitive to
those soft skills into the challenges of
coordinate
communication and you know how to power
bill nicotine
think about issues leaders so that thang
Stephen for
is experiences
well thanks